the earliest event in the chucky
timeline is september 1866 when the
hackensack mayor's house is built and
then we don't know anything after that
for another 93 years until the birth of
charles lee ray on march 12th 1959. we
don't see chucky's date of birth
anywhere so how do i know that it occurs
in 1959 to begin this newspaper article
states that his parents were killed on
his seventh birthday this is confusing
because another article states rey
parents slain eight-year-old charles
orphan that means that one of these
articles has to be wrong if we count the
candles on his cake there are seven of
them and on the radio we hear the killer
is loose that same day let's make an
excuse for the filmmakers and just say
that this article came out a year after
the killing took place the rey parents
were slaying the now eight-year-old
charles was orphaned if we saw more of
this text it would be something along
the lines of police were called last
night to 987 sherwood lane only to
discover what must have been a shocking
display of murder in the mid-century
modern home that's what paper said one
year ago it's not unheard of for
journalists to do a follow-up story on
the anniversary of an event so let's
just go with that this headline from
march 12th 1965 mentions a gruesome
double homicide this is most likely
charles parents so let's just
tentatively put 1965 down is the year
that charles turns from six years old to
seven the other day we can fill in is in
1972 as shown by the title text here
when charles was 14 years old as shown
by the credits of that episode it
doesn't say if this scene takes place
before or after his birthday that year
but it must be after so charles started
the year as a 13 year old we know he
didn't start the year as a 14 year old
and turn 15 that year because in order
for that to be possible his 7th birthday
would have been in 1964. in this shot in
episode 1 it clearly shows charles and
his mom both alive in 1965. that means
his parents must have been killed on his
seventh birthday sometime after that in
1965. so we can fill out that he was 13
to begin the year in 1972 and the rest
of the calendar fills out evenly which
leaves us with march 12 1959 is the year
that charles was born if you want to
know the date of everything else in the
franchise stick around to the end of
this video
it appears to be that same year 1972
when charles leaves the wayward boys
home the next known event is the birth
of andy barkley on november 9 1982. how
do i know this in child's play 1 we see
charles get killed in the early hours of
the morning transfer his soul into
chucky and chucky is given to andy on
his sixth birthday so charles death day
is the same day as andy's birthday in
bride of chucky and in season 1 episode
3 we see that charles died on november 9
1988. subtract the six years of andy's
life before meeting chucky and you have
andy's date of birth november 9th 1982.
and yes i'm aware of this file in
child's play too that lists andy's
birthday as january 4 1983 but remember
this was just the toy company's file on
him it was the 80s they didn't have the
internet and probably just had bad info
we can throw that out then there's the
beginning of charles crime career in
1984 according to a newspaper seen in
curse this is assuming nobody ever found
out that he killed his mom or the
janitor at the orphanage this is
probably the same year that he met
tiffany because we see them commit
crimes together right away chucky and
tiffany get their pontiac in 1987 and
move to chicago shortly after in 1988.
so then we have november 9 1988 the day
that charles dies and transfers his soul
into the dawn which is also the day nika
is born because we see charles go from
his apartment with tiffany to the room
that he's keeping the pregnant sarah
captive in to the toy store where he
shot and yes i'm aware of this paper in
curse that claims that charles was
killed the day before december 27 1988
we know that the tombstones and the
other newspapers are correct however and
this article is not because there are no
christmas decorations seen anywhere in
the original child's play it was just a
typo okay a severe and continuous typo
and yes i'm aware of this chart in cult
that claims that nika was born in 87
rather than 88 this also has to be a
typo because we literally see nika being
born and it leads right into child's
play so child's play starts on november
9th 1988 and takes place over a few days
eddie caputo blows up on the 10th nor
shoots chucky on the 11. on december 29
1988 andy gives an interview in his
tabloid newspaper then there's child's
play too all we know is that it takes
place in october of 1990 based on the
fact that andy is slightly older and
this calendar where the first of the
month is on a monday the only year in
that vicinity where october starts on a
monday is in 1990 on to child's play 3
chucky finds andy's file in a computer
and states his present age is 16 years
old if andy turned 6 in november 1988
then his 16th birthday is november 1998.
in child's play 3 we see snow on the
ground but it looks like it's melting as
if it's early spring in 1999 in bride of
chucky tiffany reunites with chucky and
says i know it took me 10 years to find
you this would not be long after the 10
year mark from chucky's death meaning
that bride of chucky probably takes
place in spring 1999 as well this checks
out because she would have found out
that chuckie was back shortly after he
was shredded in the fan in child's play
3. she went straight to retrieve the
pieces there's also a sticker on jesse's
car and bride that says 1298 those
stickers are usually valid for six
months so yeah it's more evidence that
we're still in the first half of 1999.
there's another time skip before seed of
chucky the movie set scene takes place
on march 18th 2004 as seen on the date
of that day's issue of variety and the
film takes place over a few days until
the 21st then there's an epilogue scene
five years later which is glenn and
glenda's birthday party they were born
on the final night of the main story of
seed the 21st so this is now march 21
2009. we don't actually see the date of
curse of chucky until the opening
credits of the movie after them it's
cult of chucky where we found out the
little girl who survived alice was found
on january 8th 2013. it doesn't look all
that cold in curse but maybe it was a
warm winter nico was ruled insane in her
trial a few months later on april 7 2013
at some point after that chucky finds
out how to split his soul up into
multiple dolls and sends one of them to
attack andy which andy captures and
tries to use as proof that nika is not
crazy on november 1st 2013. he's not
successful but he publishes the video
online that same day
wait a minute there's two of them yes
there are multiple chuckies already so
another one of them is sent to attack
andy at his apartment this is the
epilogue of curse stated to be six
months after nica's trial that puts it
in late october or early november
actually we know it's early november
because of this line yeah i'm definitely
coming for my birthday tomorrow which
means the date is november 8 2013 the
day before andy's 25th birthday the next
action would go down almost four years
after this
[Music]
nearly four years go by before the main
events of cult of chucky
in the past four years you've had to
accept some hard truths about yourself
chucky starts taking victims at the
asylum on january 24th 2017 because we
see the date listed in this perez hilton
article some of the top related stories
during articles and cults are about
obamacare in the trump wall so january
2017 seems accurate since this was not
long before obama's term as u.s
president ended and trump's term began
finally that brings us to chucky season
one some people have suggested that this
takes place right after cult of chucky
in 2017 however it actually takes place
in 2021 and i have plenty of proof my
only note is that like many tv shows
made in the 20s this seems to take place
in a world where kovid 19 never happened
please take me there chucky first
re-emerges in hackensack in mid-march
which we can see is where the murder
rate spikes on this graph this has got
to be march 2021 because devin says
in the past year alone our murder rate
has spiked 25 percent but the series
doesn't start until october 18th the
date we can derive from the fact that
lucas wheeler's headstone lists his
death is october 19th 2021 and we first
meet him one day before that it stated
that jake misses a week of school after
this in episode 2 a title card says hack
and sack present day the episode takes
place on halloween and indeed it did
come out the week of halloween in 2021
that means episode 3 which would be the
day after is set on november 1st the
song that they listened to at lexi's
silent disco party came out in 2020 so
it can't still be 2017. the song wasn't
out yet episode 4 looks like it's the
next morning november 2nd in this one
chucky refers to lexi as a karen on
training wheels even though kovit didn't
happen in this universe i'm still going
to assume that karen's made themselves
known in 2020. the confusion comes about
in episode 5. nika after being possessed
by the soul of charles lee ray regains
control of her body and asks this guy
for the days he tells her it's november
8th and she says spin two wings this led
some people to believe that chucky
season one takes place in 2017 two weeks
after cult of chucky however that
doesn't make sense november does not
take place two weeks after january what
most likely happened is that nika is
basically asleep whenever chucky is in
control of her body she might have
temporarily gotten control back in
october 2017 or october 2018 1920. it
doesn't really matter and then chucky
was in control for one or more years
after that when nika regained control on
november 8th 2021 she assumed that only
two weeks had passed when it had
actually been years if you need any more
proof that it's 2021 look at this
conversation that jake and devon have
about horror movies favorite random girl
lori strode hands down jamie is going to
win the saturn this year dude she's
going to win an oscar she's magnificent
they must be talking about halloween
kills from 2021 because jamie lee curtis
was not in any movies in 2017. the rest
of the season just takes place in
mid-november we don't know the exact
date but in episode six there's an intro
scene which is the first time we see
andy barkley in the show it appears to
happen right after episode 5 which would
mean that andy is reintroduced on his
birthday again which is kind of fun the
last thing to figure out is how long
andy was in captivity after colt i
googled andy barklane got an article
from two weeks ago violent patient
escapes hair gate psychiatric hospital
mana underway that would mean that andy
didn't escape until october 25th 2021 so
he was actually in harrogate for almost
five years however in the same episode
jake says this i got a call from rhode
island about a month ago there must be
andy barkley we saw that phone call in
episode one meaning that it happened on
october 19th six days before andy
supposedly escaped andy is a pretty
crafty guy and the hospital was left
very short-staffed after the events of
cult i think what happened here is that
andy escaped a while ago they just
didn't realize he escaped until much
later he might have escaped the previous
winter because the epilogue of colts
shows kyle in the winter and putting
away the chuck he had at andy's request
we can assume it took some time for andy
and kyle to meet up again after that i
don't know how andy pulled off this
whole escape without them realizing but
he probably tricked one of the new
incoming patients into pretending to be
him and took advantage of a new staff
member that didn't know names and faces
yet so i just wanted to make this video
to clarify my current views on the
chucky timeline before i start making
any more chucky horror history episodes
so i can focus more on the character
analysis when i do make those i am
getting eye surgery soon that's why i'm
wearing glasses lately i'm gonna try not
to miss a week but if i do that's
probably why if this ends up being my
last video ever then i guess i got final
destination 5. but for the event that
that doesn't happen please subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell and set it to all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]
you